today we're going droning droning we're
going to fly drones so have an old
phantom3 the Jenna's gonna be using and
we're running into a few issues here's
the issue
ah it's legit the worst sound in the
world
Oh row second works on horse yeah no
one's here like what are you saying to
me I'm losing my mind oh I'm updating
firmware for four hours
I've tried updating the controller
hardware malfunction contact DGI support
for repairs Bob I don't understand what
do you want from me the Phantom 4 is so
easy updo tell me what you want all
right Jenna sorry this was gonna be your
drone but I can't figure out what's due
my fly drone so first we're gonna stop
and get some brunch
Maddie's allowed to be there too we call
it an ass Matthew yes the dog oops
Matthew please blower no this place is
so cute and Maddie's gonna take a poo I
love exploring Malibu because we don't
ever really come here that often because
traffic is usually awful and the only
time fit everyone's really available as
usual in a weekend and that's when the
traffic in hope just right in there
honey
just jump right in the bus
you
we've on Jenna in the box
Jenna didn't believe me Matt's a dirty
chai with the thing and she's like I
think that was joking with me so I would
always tell her to get me in an overtime
with a shirt over uh that's not a bad
dirty chai isn't like let's roll let's
finally go fly these drones one drone is
clearly to drill who's not gonna happen
window well good
steps out there then clothes boy dear
goodness gee golly Matthew we finally
found a safe place to fly the drone
we're just gonna get quick shot and look
too bad we fly it straight here we'll
get a nice quick shot up and back
none of our roads not near people I like
to be safe no catastrophes guys no
catastrophes sending you both thought
you didn't know I'm left without you
come Oh in my world of magic
accidentally tragic it should never have
we never let's go let's go we keeping
all the features
Wow
I think we might have got some cool
shots gets get Maddie you'll see it and
offer you our vlogs so stay tuned for
that
Donna what happened oh you flatter
yourself
oh shut up I was sending you know
I'm lost without thought you come over
in my world of magic